u.n secretary general antonio guterres
has arrived in pakistan and called for
help to support the country's response
to the catastrophic flooding
rescue and relief efforts continue
pakistan's armed forces are racing to
get stranded people out of flooded areas
and into relief camps while water levels
are starting to recede many districts
remain under water thousands are taking
shelter at roadsides on higher ground
the floods have affected some 33 million
people and caused more than a thousand
deaths
well joining us now from islamabad is
adil sharaz that's pakistan's country
director for the aid organization care
thanks for being with us the un
secretary general is visiting pakistan
today he's already appealed to the world
for help and dealing with the aftermath
of the floods what does what does
pakistan need most urgently right now
you know it is still the initial days of
the emergency and
our teams are in the field and they are
looking at the needs on ground
at this stage food is one of the major
need which is required because more and
more people are affected and they have
lost everything so there will be a
regular need of food for a couple of
more weeks
shelter is another major need and then
waterborne diseases are increasing so
medical assistance required at
different affected population area in
terms of like you know treating cholera
malaria skin diseases and other things
so that's another essential area
sanitation facilities
are also required because people have
been displaced and they don't have these
infrastructure which they had before
and then uh clean drinking water so
these are the top most essential needs
at this stage okay
now aid is coming in
to some degree from abroad but it's
pakistan's government that has to deal
with this emergency directly
how is the government coping
government have been providing
a very good support to the affected
population but we also need to
understand that some massive flooding
there's a large population which is
affected and as i shared earlier that
there are things which are required one
time maybe like shelter and other things
but then food supplies are required on a
regular basis
so that requires a lot of support not
only internally from the government but
also from the international actors the
government is also playing a very key
role in terms of providing cash
assistance to the affected families
through an income support program which
already exists in the country
but
as an aid worker and
for the international community they
also need to understand that so it's a
massive flood and we are talking about
more than six million people who need
urgent support
how difficult is it ideal for an aid
organization like yours to help the
people who need it how difficult is it
to reach the people under these
conditions
there are still some areas which are
under water and
the water will remain there for a couple
of more weeks but then when we have
visited different parts of sin province
and balochistan province people have
also moved from the affected area to the
nearby roadside areas so at least those
people who are living nearby the road
those people are accessible but there
are still some affected communities who
are living in the
their villages which are still flooded
with the water so it's slightly
challenging to reach out to them but at
the same time
some of the key department from the
government are also helping out to reach
out to them either through their direct
support or through the other aid
organization support
and since the government infrastructure
is large so that is helping out to
reaching out to the affected community
but we also need to understand with
bridges and roads were washed away
so the rebuilding work is continuing and
with that i think like each day is is a
better day than before in terms of
accessing people
huge challenges still lie ahead adil
shiraz the country director of care
pakistan thank you so much
thank you
you